for three days France has been gripped
by an unfolding drama of unprecedented
violence the terror that was unleashed
does that first burst of gunfire rip
through the Charlie Hebdo office on a
quiet Wednesday morning in Paris sent
shockwaves through Europe it is
triggered once more
agonized debate about freedom of speech
and liberty that keystone of the French
states
we're also getting explosions now
and it has raised questions about how
the security services monitor the threat
from Islamic extremists who have come to
hate the nations in which they were born
people's which is the monster the human
race cannot be stopped by hatred
presidents decided together led to shout
of the plasma Republic we are not afraid
an attack in broad daylight in the heart
of Paris two heavily armed gunmen making
their escape they've already killed and
we're about to add more victims to their
slaughter this police officer lying on
the ground has been shot and injured
approaching in combat mode before
shooting him again at point-blank range
gloating about the bloodshed as they
calmly make their getaway what I saw
were the end of the shooting people
trying to escape and policemen arriving
on the scene very quickly and
unfortunately for one of them he tried
to fight and he tried to run towards the
gunman and he was shot he was shot down
in cold blood
the gunman left behind a scene of
unimaginable horror paramedics and
police officers descending on the site
of the attack confronted with the
aftermath of a bloodbath
the wounded some critically poured out
onto the streets seeking help inside the
building their dead colleagues
journalists and illustrators of the
magazine Charlie Hebdo we saw a lot of
bodies that were already on the ground
some of them looked clearly dead so
there was nothing much we could do so we
did that and then we waited for the
rescue teams to come in and within
minutes the place was completely packed
with the police the emergency teams and
and so on and so forth so we just at
some point an authoritative voice rose
from the crowd and they said well look
everybody is still alive leave the room
and so we just left and then we were
sort of outside in our own office among
those killed stefan Shabani a editor of
the weekly publication he'd received
threats before but defended cartoons
featuring the Prophet Mohammed once
saying I'd prefer to die standing than
live on my knees Oh me it's likely
volume you lost the Prophet Mohammed is
sacred to Muslims and I can understand
that but for Muslims only I'm an atheist
Muhammad is not sacred to me I
understand that Muslims don't violate
their level of blasphemy and I don't
blame them for not finding our cartoons
funny but they shouldn't tell me under
which law I should live also murdered
the magazine's lead cartoonist Jean Kabu
and George will insky an eight-year-old
satirist had been drawing cartoons since
the 1960s
me in your bed they killed my daddy
but they didn't kill their ideas pickled
men and that's the way it is but thanks
to all this show of solidarity thanks to
all these people full of love who are
rebelling
we're going to be able to do something
from it we're going to be able to fight
gradually the sequence of events became
clear at 11:30 the gunmen arrive at rue
Nicola a pair in a black Citroen car
armed with ak-47s and a grenade launcher
they ask maintenance man Frederick
Warsaw for directions to the Charlie
Hebdo office before shooting him dead at
the front door they forced cartoonist
Kareem Rae and her young daughter to let
them in they make their way to the
second floor where the editor is
chairing a meeting
they killed police officer Frank Brin
solaro who is guarding the editor
because of previous threats the gunman
then asked for Stefan Shibani a by name
and shoot him dead before killing
cartoonists George Wolinsky Jean Kabu
bernard bellick and philippe honoré as
well as writer bernard mahi they also
murdered columnist Elsa Kai at sub
editor Mustafa rod and Michelle canard a
visitor ten other people are also
injured after five minutes the gunmen
flee around the corner in a levert
they're confronted by police and opened
fire leaving the patrol car riddled with
bullets on the boulevard Lenoir it's
after this police officer
amid maribeth is wounded and then killed
by the gunman before they drive off
these are the men suspected of the
atrocity their two brothers French
nationals of Algerian descent Sheriff
and Saeed cahuachi both reportedly known
to the French intelligence services
Sharif appeared in a documentary about
extremism a decade ago and was jailed in
2008 for terrorism related offences the
French police and French intelligence
services knew this group pretty well not
least because both Karate brothers had
been in prison the younger one for
sending recruits to Iraq to go and fight
for al-qaeda against the american-led
occupation the older for being part of a
plot to try to release a known terrorist
an Algerian terrorist who
part of a bombing campaign in the 1980s
from prison a prison breakout so those
two were well known on top of that the
older one went to the Yemen and actually
met with Anwar al-awlaki now he is the
what until he was killed he was probably
the most famous and certainly the most
important al Qaeda leader anywhere in
the world including Osama bin Laden as
Parisians sought to make sense of the
slaughter their leader spoke Nishikawa
Cod would you'll meet a force 80 at the
chaos Walker today France has been
attacked at it's very hard in Paris in
the building of a paper and this violent
attack killed 12 people and wounded some
more je vous avec une all today in your
name i would like to express our
gratefulness to those people who are
wounded to all those who have been
killed by this cowardly assassination
today they are our heroes of the attenti
expression freedom of expression can't
simply be attacked state authority can't
simply be attacked of course I'm
thinking about my brother it's also his
colleague who died and his wife the wife
of my brother his daughter his child and
my whole family now Vermeer world
leaders joined in the condemnation it
was not just France under attack they
said it was the principles of democracy
and the freedom of expression which were
also under threat this country stands
United with the French people in our
opposition to all forms of terrorism and
we stand squarely for free speech and
democracy to see
once again but possibly the strongest
message of defiance came from the
world's cartoonists united in grief and
galvanized in outrage their pens proving
more powerful than any terrorist weapon
did that picture because it was on a
simple picture was able to to make
something something but how to do
resistant go on and still feeling alive
despite what happened in sharia blue
there were so many talented cartoonist
as job T news in Kabul and for some
people my generation these persons were
very awesome the great influences but as
dusk fell around the world candles were
lit can crowds gathered with one message
for those who had brought terror to the
French capital
just sweep Charlene
the mood of shock and grief was still
clear the next day as Paris stood still
in defiance against the attack
I felt compelled to come here today to
stand united with Paris and to make them
aware that the whole of Europe
and the rest of the world are with them
on this tragic day the human race cannot
be stopped by hatred and I feel for the
French people I really do because we
felt it in New York and and they'll come
we'll come back stronger but now came
the first sign that the attack on
Charlie Hebdo might be a part of a
larger overarching plan to bring terror
to Paris a police woman was shot at a
metro station in the south of the
capital by a man wearing a bulletproof
vest the attack was at first believed to
be unconnected to the shali Abdo
shootings the following day that was
proved to be wrong the manhunt for the
two Sharlee of those suspects moved
rapidly to this petrol station in the
town of Villa cotta Hey
north of Paris two men mounting the
gunman's description fired shots before
stealing fuel and food a renault clio
stolen by the suspects was found
abandoned not far from the petrol
station armed police scoured woodland
and farms with helicopters hovering
overhead and police going door-to-door
it seemed that the hunt was closing in
darkness fell and the Eiffel Tower
dimmed its lights to reflect the mood of
its citizens but day three was to see an
intensification of the terror
dawn and day three began with one of the
biggest manhunts in France's history the
two brothers wanted for the massacre of
12 people were still alive
but 25 miles northeast of Paris the
search appeared to be reaching its final
stages as the net closed in reports were
emerging the Kawachi brothers had been
seen in this area now suddenly the
police had a real breakthrough
the Kawachi brothers have been forced to
dump their car as it ran out of fuel and
had now hijacked another they'd been
seen heading south back towards the
capital at half an hour later they
encountered a police roadblock
after a firefight they dumped their car
and headed on foot across a field
finding themselves in a small industrial
town of damata non-gray here they were
forced to take refuge in a local
printing work our smart customer service
appalled it was in my fee alikoya youto
India this morning what surprised me was
after dropping my daughter at school
around 8:30 8:45 there was a helicopter
hovering over my house it was very
impressive
knowing this area what happened
yesterday I thought that something must
be happening in our village or nearby
the police had their men cornered
special forces were dispatched to the
site in preparation for the final
encounter with a two men
one of the brothers spoke to a French TV
station new order digit only the
difference of the profits anomaly was an
M equals it were a more assertive quasi
/ al-qaeda demon okay super Kira bar
equals Asia
I know Allah will appeal to my
philosophy but at the same time news of
another hostage situation was breaking
in Paris worst fear is that this was
turning into a wave of coordinated
attacks as a man armed with a
Kalashnikov opened fire in a kosher
supermarket
dozens of vans carrying police and
combat gear raced through the streets of
central Paris to the scene in de Levante
sound this is the building with blue
tinted windows but it was soon becoming
clear that it was turning into another
hostage situation I need you at the
scene earlier there was an African
individual who had a Kalashnikov he was
reported as being at 23 Avenue Port the
vasa he immediately went into the
delicatessen and started shooting with
his Kalashnikov what is for sure is that
colleagues who are there have already
seen six hostages
this individual seems to be the same one
from yesterday he's African and his name
is coulibaly
sadly yesterday he already carried out
some atrocities by killing a policewoman
these are the two suspects who at the
time were believed to be involved in the
second siege 32 year old Emma D
coulibaly
and his partner 26 year old Hyatt
boumedienne police believe coulibaly is
also responsible for the shooting of the
Paris police woman Clarice's Jean
Philippe French media reporting that the
grocery hostage taker was demanding
freedom for the cahuachi brothers police
locked down the area in Portola von san
schools were evacuated all shops and the
streets were told to close and those in
nearby restaurants hid under tables
the French authorities were now facing
an unprecedented crisis two separate but
linked sieges involving hostages on two
different sites the al-qaeda playbook is
all about multiple attacks and causing
mass casualties now in this case
therefore once it was clear that these
individuals were part of the al-qaeda
franchise that they've been inspired and
trained by al-qaeda in the Arabian
Peninsula it should have been assumed
that there would be more operations
following the killings in the magazine
and then their departure it should and
then the information coming from the
Yemenis that these people were known to
the Yemeni authorities the French police
would have assumed and would have been
right that there was going to be another
attack because that's what al-qaeda does
as dusk fell in dammit on a door was
left open to the printing words
minutes later Sharif inside cahuachi
bursts through shooting and officers
special forces moved in gunfire was
exchanged and both men were killed
from the smoke emerged this man unknown
to the gunman he'd been hiding under a
sink on the second floor during the
entire operation and he'd sent police
information wire text messages his boss
Michael Catalano had been released
earlier by the gunman I didn't get the
impression they were going to harm me
even if it does seem to be unbelievable
but that's precisely the situation I
found myself in because possibly they
had an ounce of humanity so far as I was
concerned because they let me out it's
up to you it's surprising they didn't
find the other person yes well it's not
incredible it's magnificent and that's
what I was really terrified of
back in the capital a near simultaneous
assault was being planned on the Jewish
grocery store but the outcome here would
be very different
the store was surrounded and unknown to
the hostage takers
French police had hacked into the shop
CCTV system to monitor their movements
they were able to send messages to one
of the hostages inside on a mobile phone
gathering crucial information on the
situation the hostage taker Emma D
Coulibaly also decided to give an
interview to a French TV station
Esposito lyrically the fire chaos shall
you do with the to remove a cavity ice
to observe it open with a molecule no
with that second is it Gelman aquadude
was even mocked some previews away as in
are you or some to be the way most
common sense
the direct assault on the front of the
building came with risks a French
officer was struck and injured and
carried to safety by colleagues
kalabaw Li charged at police officers as
they entered he was shot dead before he
reached them he had held 19 people
hostage only 15 emerged from their
terrifying ordeal one man is surrounded
as he holds on to a distraught child
this woman's anguish clearly visible
when we went into the shop we heard a
boom and we saw a guy with a bulletproof
vest with a green jacket and two
Kalashnikovs a revolver and a knife we
were sitting down and to our right there
were two dead bodies two people that
were killed when he walked in as soon as
he came in he started shooting what
scared us is that he said I'm not
worried about dying either I will die or
go to prison for 40 years so he knew
this was his last day three days of
terror have paralyzed France the
authorities will say the attackers were
identified quickly tracked and shot dead
but they will also have to admit that
these men were known to the police as
were their links to international terror
groups hostages have been killed and a
terrorist has evaded capture and it's
not known how many others were involved
in the planning and execution of the
carnage I think the French police are
going to be dismayed with the loss of
four hostages in the Paris operation I
think they're also going to be asking
some very serious questions as to why
the two rescue operations were not
launched simultaneously the hostage
taker in the Paris Daily had said I will
kill these hostages if you launch an
operation against my friends acquire
brothers now that operation against the
kouachi brothers went off about 10 to 15
minutes before the attack went in
against the the hostage takers in the
deli
now they had surveillance we understand
inside the deli the police had hacked
into the CCTV inside that building they
had
may have also been in communication with
a hostage taker and they would have
wanted to go absolutely simultaneously
there's some evidence that they may have
delayed it because they needed the TV
cameras around them to switch off the
live feed before they could go in and if
that's the case there's going to be a
serious controversy and a lot of anger
in France as grief begins to make way
for rage there was a warning for France
and it came from a family still mourning
the loss of a loved one
hamed mara but the policemen who were so
callously murdered following the attack
on the Charlie Hebdo offices was a
Muslim a Muslim who died defending the
right to free speech Shima that's Matt
no a truly racist Islamophobe I now I'm
addressing myself to all racists the
Islamophobes
and the anti-semites you mustn't mix up
extremism with Muslims the madmen have
no colour no religion and I just like to
underline another aspect stop
associating or having Wars or burning
synagogues because you're attacking
people it won't bring back the dead and
it won't comfort the families
the terrorists who stopped Frances heart
from beating for three days wanted to
break the country into a fractured
hateful State on Sunday French citizens
have been asked to spill out onto the
streets again to prove the killers have
failed